TRUMP'S LATEST MOVE ON CHINA.
HINT, I LIKE IT A LOT.
LET'S START WITH A BIG ARGUMENT
AT THE HEART OF POSITIVE
POPULISM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: AFTER YEARS AND
YEARS BUILDING UP OTHER
COUNTRIES, WE ARE FINALLY
BUILDING UP OUR COUNTRY,
STANDING UP FOR OUR JOBS, OUR
WORKERS, AND STANDING UP FOR OUR
DIGNITY.
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN OF
AMERICA WILL NEVER EVER BE
FORGOTTEN AGAIN.
YOU WERE FORGOTTEN.
STEVE: EXACTLY.
WHAT IS INTERESTING IS DONALD
TRUMP SO COMPLETELY RESHAPED
POLITICS THAT THE 2020 DEMOCRATS
ARE TRYING TO COPY HIM BY
CLAIMING THE MANTEL OF POPULISM.
THEY ARE THE REAL POPULISTS THEY
SAID IN THEIR LAST DEBATE.
TRUMP ONLY HELPED THE RICH.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS PART OF A
CORRUPT RIGGED SYSTEM THAT HELP
THE WEALTHY AND THE
WELL-CONNECTED AND KICKED DIRT
IN THE FACES OF EVERYONE ELSE.
>> WE WATCHED DONALD TRUMP PIT
HARD WORKING PEOPLE AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
BLACK VERSUS WHITE AND CITIZEN
VERSUS IMMIGRANT SO THE AMERICA
HE REPRESENTS CAN HOLD THE
AMERICAN DREAM HOSTAGE FROM
EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> THE TOP 1% OF CORPORATIONS
WERE HELPED WHEN HE SAID HE
WOULD HELP WORKING FAMILIES.
STEVE: THIS IS THE CLAIM.
THAT HIS POLICIES ONLY HELPED
THE RICH.
THESE ARE LIES, LIES, LIES.
BETWEEN 2016 AND 2018.
CORPORATE PROFITS ROSE BY $22
BILLION WHILE WORKER EARNINGS
WENT UP FOUR TIMES MORE.
DEMOCRATS SAY TRUMP IS
CONTINUING WHAT OBAMA STARTED.
BUT THIS IS A COMPLETELY.
WORKERS' EARNING INCREASED BY
42% MORE DURING PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S FIRST TWO YEARS IN
OFFICE THAN BARACK OBAMA LAST
TWO.
IT'S A PERFECT TEST CASE OF WHAT
PRO GROWTH, PRO END PRIZE
ECONOMICS CAN DO.
IT'S TRUE CORPORATE TAX CUTS AND
DEREGULATION HELPED BUSINESSES.
BUT WHO DO YOU THINK ACTUALLY
CREATES JOBS AND PAYS WAGES?
HELPING BUSINESSES IS THE WAY
YOU HELP WORKERS.
LET ME EXPLAIN HOW IT WORKS.
LOWER TAXES AND LESS REGULATION
GIVES BUSINESSES THE CONFIDENCE
TO INVEST.
THAT MEANS MORE INNOVATION AND
HIGHER WORKER PRODUCTIVITY.
THAT MEANS MORE JOBS ARE CREATED
AND WORKERS ARE PAID MORE
BECAUSE THEY ARE PRODUCING MORE.
ON JOB THE LATEST REPORT SHOWS
164,000 JOBS WERE ADDED,
BRINGING THE LABOR FORWARD TO
163 MILLION.
A NEW ALL-TIME RECORD.
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP WE HAVE
SEEN THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT IN
50 YEARS AND THE LOWEST ON
RECORD.
THE LATEST DATA ON EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION SHOWS EARNINGS ROSE
EVEN HIGHER THAN PREVIOUSLY
REPORTED.
AND WAY AHEAD OF INFLATION.
BUT THE BEST NEWS IS ON LOW
INCOME WORKERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SPECIFICALLY
DELIVERING ON THE PROMISES HE
MADE TO THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND
WOMEN WHO REVOLTED AGAINST AN
ESTABLISHMENT THAT PUNISHED THEM
WITH FREE TRADE, OPEN BORDERS
AND GLOBALIZATION.
INCOMES ARE RISING FASTEST FOR
THE LOWEST PAID.
HOURLY PAY GROWTH FOR THE BOTTOM
25% HAS OUTPACED THAT OF HIGHER
EARNERS EVERY MONTH OF THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
IN BLUE COLLAR INDUSTRIES LIKE
MINING, CONSTRUCTION AND
TRANSPORTATION.
IT FAR EXCEEDS WHAT WE SAW UNDER
OBAMA'S SECOND TERM.
WHICH ALL THE ESTABLISHMENT
EXPERTS SAID WAS IMPOSSIBLE BY
THE WAY.
JOBS ARE COMING BACK IN NUMBERS
WE HAVEN'T SEEM FOR DECADES.
LAST YEAR'S GAIN OF 264,000
MANUFACTURING JOBS WAS THE
HIGHEST SINCE 1997.
THE FACTS DEMONSTRATE
CONCLUSIVELY THAT WORKING
AMERICANS ARE THE WINNERS IN THE
TRUMP ECONOMY.
YES, HE IS THE REAL POPULIST AND
IT'S THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE FAKE.
THEY WANT TO REVERSE THE TAX
CUTS AND DEREGULATION.
THEY WANT TO MAKE ENERGY MORE
EXPENSIVE.
ASK PRESIDENT MACRON IN FRANCE
WHAT WORKING PEOPLE THINK OF
THAT.
HE STILL HAS PROTESTS IN THE
STREETS OVER GREEN POLICIES THAT
ARE MILD COMPARED TO WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS WANT HERE.
AND ALL OF THEM WANT A MASSIVE
EXPANSION IN GOVERNMENT PAID FOR
BY YOU.
THAT'S NOT JUST A TAX GRAB, IT'S
A POWER GRAB.
POPULISM IS ABOUT POWER TO THE
PEOPLE.
THE LEFT ARE ABOUT TAKING POWER
AWAY FROM PEOPLE AND GIVING IT
TO THEIR GOVERNMENT.
THERE IS ONE MORE ARGUMENT.
WE NEED TO DEMOLISH THAT BE TOO.
THIS COMES NOT FROM THE LEFT,
BUT FROM THE NEVER TRUMPERS AND
THE REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT.
THEY SAY DONALD TRUMP MAY HAVE A
GOOD ECONOMY.
BUT THAT'S JUST BECAUSE OF
TRADITIONAL CONSERVATIVE
POLICIES.
WHERE HE MOVED AWAY FROM
REPUBLICAN ORTHODOXY ITS BEEN A
DISASTER.
THIS IS TOTAL B.S.
AS WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU,
TARIFFS WORK.
THEY WORKED ON THE BORDER WITH
MEXICO AND THEY ARE WORKING WITH
CHINA.
THE WAY THE CRITICS TALK YOU
WHAT
-AT
--T
--YOU WOULD THINK OUR ENTIRE
ECONOMY IS DEPENDENT ON CHINA.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THE TRADE
WAR WITH CHINA HAS INTRODUCED
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY AND THAT'S
NEVER A GOOD THING.
THE DEMOCRAT FAKE MEDIA IS
HYPING UP A RECESSION.
THEY THINK IT' THE BEST WAY TO
GET RID OF TRUMP.
HERE IS WHAT ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI
HAS BEEN SAYING.
SOMEWHAT HE HAS DONE ON THE
TRADE SITUATION HAS DESTABILIZED
THE WORLD ECONOMY.
IT'S HURTING THEM AND IT'S
HURTING THE ENTIRE CAP HALLMARK
THE SYSTEM.
STEVE: HE JUST GAVE THE GAME
AWAY.
HE ACTUALLY WROTE A BOOK CALLED
THE BLUE COLLAR PRESIDENT AND
CAME ON THIS SHOW TO PROMOTE IT.
BUT NOW WE SEE WHICH SIDE HE'S
REALLY ON, THE WALL STREET
WHEELER DEALERS, HE CALLED IT
THE CAPITAL MARKET SYSTEM THAT
HAS SCREWED WORKERS TO MAKE
THEMSELVES RICH.
THEY ARE DUMPING ON TRUMP JUST
AT THE MOMENT WHEN HIS POPULIST
TRADE POLICIES ARE STARTING TO
WORK.
FOR 50 YEARS CHINA WAS MOVING
TOWARD ITS STATED AIM OF
TOPPLING AMERICA AS THE WORLD'S
ECONOMIC AND MILITARY SUPER
POWER.
NOT LEAST BY CHEATING ON TRADE
RULES AND STEELING TECHNOLOGY.
NOW THANKS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
CHINA IS REELING AS A DIRECT
RESULTL RESULT OF THE TRUMP
TARIFFS, MANUFACTURERS ARE
MOVING SUPPLY CHAINS OUT OF
CHINA.
CHINA'S ECONOMIC GROWTH HAS
SLUMPED TO THE LOWEST IN NEARLY
30 YEARS.
ESTABLISHMENT CRITICS SAY OUR
GROWTH IS DOWN, TOO.
BUT IT WAS HIGHER THAN ANYONE
EXPECTED.
EACH U. GROWTH WAS LESS THAN
HALF AS MUCH.
AND THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT RATES
WERE 7.5%.
THEY THOUGHT THAT WAS GOOD.
IT WAS DOWN SLIGHTLY.
BUT IT'S MORE THAN TWICE AS HIGH
AS OURS.
THE ESTABLISHMENT LOVES TO
REGURGITATE THE TIRED TALKING
POINTS ABOUT CONSUMERS PAYING
FOR THE TRADE WAR.
THAT THEY ARE IDIOTICALLY
SHORT-SIGHTED.
THEY DON'T TAKE ACCOUNT OF THE
COST TO OUR SOCIETY AND OUR
ECONOMY OF SHIPPING JOBS TO
CHINA SO THEY CAN SHIP CHEAP
PRODUCTS BACK HERE.
WE HAD A FANTASTIC DEBATE ON
THIS.
IT'S WORTH SIGNING UP TO
foxnation.
THE MARKET PRICE OF THAT CHEAP
T-SHIRT AND TV DID NOT INCLUDE
THE DEVASTATION OF THAT TOWN IN
IOWA.
WELFARE PAYMENT OR DEALING
OPIOID.
SO YOU HAVE GOT THAT GOING ON.
THERE IS A HUGE SET OF SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC COSTS THAT ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE PRICE OF THAT
CHEAP T-SHIRT.
ALL I CAN SAYING IS YOU INCLUDE
IT IN THE REAL PRICE BY PUTTING
A MASS TOUGH TARIFF ON ANY
T-SHIRT MADE OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY
SO IT'S EQUAL AND YOU MIGHT AS
WELL MAKE IT HERE BECAUSE IT
WON'T BE ANY CHEAPER IF YOU
IMPORT IT.
THAT WOULD BE MY POLICY.
IF YOU WANT TO SELL IT IN
AMERICA, YOU CAN DAMN WELL MAKE
IT IN AMERICA.
IT'S TIME FOR A COMPLETE
ECONOMIC BOYCOTT OF CHINA.
ALL U.S. COMPANIES IN CHINA
SHOULD PULL OUT AND NO NEW
INVESTMENT SHOULD BE MADE.
THE ESTABLISHMENT JUST DON'T GET
THE HISTORIC GEOSTRATEGIC TURN
OUR  * TRUMP TARIFFS ARE -- TURN
AROUND TRUMP TARIFFS ARE
BRINGING.
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN TO STOP CHINA
CHEATING US.
WHAT'S YOUR PLAN TO STOP CHINA
BEATING US?
THESE TRUMP TARIFFS ARE THE
FIRST THING IN 50 YEARS THAT
HAVE GOT CHINA'S ATTENTION AND
THEY ARE RESHAPING THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY TO AMERICA'S ADVANTAGE.
ALL THAT WOULD BE PUT AT RISK BY
THIS MAN.
ON THE DEFINING ISSUE OF OUR
AGE, THE DEMOCRATS SEEM HELL
BENT ON NOMINATING SOMEONE FOR
PRESIDENT WHO IS TOTALLY
COMPROMISED BY OUR GREATEST
ENEMY CHINA.
JOE BIDEN TOOK OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN PRESCRIBES FROM THE
CHINESE REGIME IN THE FORM OF
PAYMENTS TO BIDEN FAMILY
BUSINESSES.
IN 2016 WE SAW THE TRUE GENIUS
OF THIS COUNTRY.
AMERICA ELECTED AS PRESIDENT THE
ONLY PERSON WHO WAS PREPARED TO
CONFRONT THE GREATEST CHALLENGE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT JUST THE
REAL POPULIST.
HE'S THE SUCCESSFUL POPULIST.
WHERE HE FOLLOWED CON ECONOMICS
AND TAX CUTS AND DEREGULATION,
THE RESULTS HAVE BEEN GREAT,
ESPECIALLY FOR WORKING
AMERICANS.